hey guys Dimitri from the score eSports
now when we create these top-ten lists
for dota we usually limit our criteria
to professional matches only but we'd be
lying if we said we weren't tempted to
venture into a pub every once in a while
apart from scrims
public matchmaking is the best place for
pros to push the boundaries and create
some truly awe-inspiring place don't I
dodge the ulti bro big plays big please
[Music]
big big plays big plays from daring
Aegis snatches to mind-bending
predictions some of the best plays in
dota happen when a pro is streaming
directly from their bedroom that's why
this week we're counting down the top 10
pro pub plays in dota 2 coming in at
number 10 is our t Z's insane Spectre
escape our tour spidey senses must have
been tingling on this one as he
preemptively baited one of his manta
illusions just milliseconds before he
was gay he then used Hans to dodge ember
spirits fire remnant movie confusing his
opponents in the process while also
buying himself enough time to grab a
teleport scroll and retreat back to base
holy [ __ ] like by the way check out
ember spirits final sleight of fist
missing
there's no way our TZ would have had
enough HP to make it out if that hit
connected missed it by that much coming
in at number nine we have the time that
syncs things VIPRE turned a tier 1 tower
dive into a fountain dive and made it
out alive in the process that's right
you heard me from tier 1 tower to the
enemy fountain it's as cloudy as it is
impressive this is no what I wanted to
happen
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
seriously housing showing that with you
[Music]
know about - actually continuing to blow
people's minds is eternal envy and his
unorthodox fountain glimpse strategy
which makes its way in at number eight
on our list
Oh me lunch can we come to take her to
her can we take her to our side I'll
kill him
rocket rocket rocket rocket guns rocket
clothes rocket wings use rocket hair and
we can glimpse the ticker noticing that
his Rubik still had disruptors glimpse
available eternalenvy coordinated his
teammates to send the respawning tanker
back to where he was last killed which
was the other side of the map
he then teleported bottom to catch the
tanker and secure the game poor guy
didn't even know what hit him
here's about a Castleberry keyboard
useful front guys we couldn't do this
list without including at least one of
attackers god-like conca plays admiral
kunkka the devil to pay who set sail
will fail after scouting an enemy bounty
hunter in the top lane attack her x
marks themself boots of travels top and
throughout a blind torrent that caught
the invisible hero he then followed that
stun up with a ghost ship while also
cleaving off the enemy creep wave just
in time before the x mark brought him
back to base i troll your guts with my
blade
okay that was that's was really good I
mean I was [ __ ] surprised that that
that thicket to talk proving that
supports are just as capable of carrying
games is monkeys forever and his
hilariously game-winning shadow shaman
clutch yo can we work on a not lose the
game plan apparently doing it with a
nagging of scepter and refresher Orban
hand monkeys forever puts the rest of
his team on his back and carries them to
victory styling on anyone who dares to
stand in his way you play to win the
game you don't play to just play out of
maybe no oh my lord
coming in at number five is Thompson's
morphling running an absolute clinic in
a 1v3 situation Mark Waters after a
failed initiation from Earth Spirit
Thompson activates his bottle haste rune
and dives the radiant tier 1 tower in
order to take out the enemy Zeus staying
calm under pressure tops and morphs
himself into the enemy Earth Spirit and
uses his spells to full effect
all the while using his attribute shift
to increase his strength to withstand
everything the radiant has to throw at
it
absolutely the radiant tries to avenge
their Zeus but end up making things
worse as they are baited into fading
away their lives to the reigning Ti
champion
hey one more although you bait it like
that di winner others getting baited by
the coming in at number four is gunner
signature ember spirit with quite
possibly the sexiest Aegis steel of all
time and we know after using sleight of
fist to get an idea of how low Roshan
was gunner through a fire remnant
directly into the pit
he then activated his other defensive
remnant and picked up the aegis along
the way if that wasn't impressive enough
gunner also ended up stealing the kill
on Roshan securing bonus gold for his
team in the process now that's some off
food thief in the night inspired [ __ ] if
I have ever seen your opponent's Bamber
coming in at number three is avec and
his fountain zip across the map with
storm spirits in this clip
abed times his expiring ages and uses
the mana regeneration to make a huge dip
across the map wiping out the enemy team
in the process get set by heavy where
that
[Music]
my team my team is dead too bad it was
an eternal envy doing this because that
was anime as hell
[Music]
coming in at the runner-up spot is
miracle and his infamous blink
prediction play realizing he wouldn't be
able to time his ultimate with the tail
end of queen of pains eul's scepter
miracle blinks into the enemy base and
starts channeling his Requiem of souls
predicting his opponent would blink to
the exact same spot seriously it's as if
miracle Newark [ __ ] was going even before
she did
coming in at the number one spot is none
other than our TZ and his mesmerizing
ember spirit double bait play disturb me
after scouting out the enemy alchemists
gank our tour waited until the last
second before activating his fire
remnant retreating and ultimately
forcing the invisible alchemists to stun
himself he then immediately teleported
back to lane and baited out faceless
voids chrono sphere before locking both
his enemies in place with searing chains
the evil genius used every tool
available to outmaneuver his opponents
not once but twice
making them look like a bunch of 2k
scrubs
well guys that's our video now before
you all hop into solo queue and hunt for
that juicy +25 make sure to LIKE the
video subscribe to the channel and let
us know in the comments what other dota2
top tens you'd like to see for me I'm
gonna go double down on some ranked
games hopefully you'll see me next time
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else
hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Music]